one of the biggest breakthroughs I had
in gym launch my first company that we
sold for just under 50 million dollars
was that in the very beginning I
actually didn't call it gym launch it
was called gym rescue and when I called
a gym rescue and I started calling
people and saying hey do you want to
work with me I'm Jim Rescue all these
gym owners were like I want to be
rescued like I'm not a damseling Express
and so I thought Bar Rescue I would just
copy the same thing but that wasn't the
case at all I had to switch from gym
rescue to gym launch and then all of a
sudden I'd have the same phone call and
they'd be like oh yeah you can launch my
gym and then I think to myself I was
like your Gym's already open we're not
really launching it but because of how
we packaged the service the reception of
what we were selling increased
dramatically so whatever you're doing in
your business if you can think of a way
to package it that edifies the prospect
that makes them look or feel cool or
give them status as a result of doing
business with you you will sell more
people